we are taking your calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 let's go next to our caller from
the 6 to 6 area code who's calling today
from 6 to 6 a David first I'm calling
but I love your show thank you so look
the Democratic establishment will stop
at nothing to make sure that Bernie
Sanders is there's not the nominee right
disgusting to watch and you know it's
been reported that even though Barack
Obama is not officially endorsing
anybody he called a Pete bootie judge
told him to drop out and endorse Joe
Biden he may have even call it a better
or or told him to do the same thing it
worse by where's that being reported I I
heard from a rebel HQ okay I don't know
but listen so here's the thing here's
the thing you're absolutely right and
this is how politics works right this is
not super-delegates this is the DNC
realizing hey we probably have a
coalition here Bernie probably has some
ceiling the pundits were very wrong
about what that ceiling was they said it
was 15 20 25 Bernie got to 30 okay
but this is how politics works this is
the game they played it and they are
winning and it sucks and the progressive
movement needs to realize that you know
that when we talk about unilateral
disarmament we don't take PAC money and
we don't do this and we don't do that in
Bubba Bubba but at a certain point
there's a line at which well then you're
gonna lose and that is going to prohibit
you from then getting into a position to
make the change that you want the I do
believe that we progressives need to
take a lesson from this though which is
a very specific one which is you know
we're in online media my a lot of people
who watch the show love Bernie a lot of
people who follow me on Twitter love
Bernie a lot of people on our subreddit
love Bernie this is not representative
of the Democratic Party at large it's
just not right because when you combine
of the the realities in a lot of these
different states you realize a lot of
people just didn't want to vote for
Bernie that's it like yes of course the
DNC orchestrated the timing of this
there
no doubt if it had been a to candidate
race from the beginning we might have
had different results all along but we
also shouldn't assume that if you just
explained Bernie's positions to people
everyone will want to vote for him
there's people who just don't want to
vote for Bernie and in that you in the
eulogy if there is one which we're not
doing right now we'll have to talk about
the way Bernie's campaign was framed
democratic socialism we'll have to talk
about all of these different things and
discuss the effect they had but yeah I
did this is just the reality and
progressives we progressives have to
face it so I guess my question is what
do you think okay so the Democrats
nominee Joe Biden Joe Biden loses to
trump in on last night because he's
corrupt what do you think of the
progressives the progresses leaving just
completely abandoning the Democratic
Party right and creating their own party
good so let's say you know and the
Democratic Party could happen but I want
to throw something else out about a
month and a half ago I game doubt the
four ways that this could go the four
ways it could go are Bernie nominated
and becomes president Bernie nominated
and loses the Trump Biden nominated and
becomes President Biden nominated and
loses to trump and when I did that story
I said if you take everything into
consideration if you take the Senate
balance into consideration if you take
all these different things long term the
best outcome for the progressive
movement might be that Biden is
nominated and loses now I won't redo the
analysis now because so many of my
audience members have already heard it
it's a long term plan and it's difficult
but it may not be the worst thing for
the progressive movement and I explain
why in that segment yeah tired well
thank you David I appreciate you
answering my call all right my pleasure
thank you so much for for calling in
let's go next to our caller from the 786
area code
who's calling today from 786
I David thanks for taking my phone call
I just have one question I'll take it
off the air I've been hearing a lot
about different voting Courage's going
on in Wisconsin Georgia and Ohio in
different areas but I never hear
anything about any type of movement to
get more voters registered or you know
any type of that type of stuff going on
in those areas so I just wondering if
you knew of anything that was going on
in those areas and I'll take the answer
off here thank you yeah sure well I mean
listen there's voter registration drives
happening all the time candidates run a
lot of voter registration drives there
or you know nonpartisan organizations or
students rights organizations they do it
just doesn't get the attention that
pulling 300,000 people off of the voter
rolls at a suspicious time and
disproportionately in democratic voting
areas gets it just doesn't get the
attention but I've long said that
elections often hinge on who decides to
get out and vote rather than individuals
who are convinced to vote one way versus
the other and it should get more
attention and we are we are up against
it no matter who the nominee is in the
Democratic primary and we may soon know
we are up against the same stuff as we
were up against last time and the time
before that and the time before that and
the time before that which is that voter
suppression is a tool that Republicans
in this country use to win elections
that's not going to change that I can
assure you